[موسيقى]
دق دق دق دق يا دقدق بصحبه ماما راح السوق
ماما ستفتح له الحلو وسياره بمقودها بوق
دق دق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق دق يا دقدق
بصحبه ماما راح السوق ماما ستبتع له الحلو
وسياره بمقودها بوق دق دق دق يا دقدق لكن
دق دقداك شقي
قد ازعج كلب الحرف
طارده فانقلب المتجر واحتاج لعوض فوري دق
دق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق يا دقدوق سحب
كذلك سله بيض
تتناثر سقط على الارض
قالت ماما ما تفسده لاصلحه احتاج لقرض دق
دق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق دق يا دقدق
بصحبه ماما راح السوق ماما ستبتع له الحلو
وسياره بمقودها بوق دق دق دق دق يا دقدق
ذهب لمحل الالعاب بالردهه يجري دقدوق كسر
من العجله الدولاب وتحطم ايضا صندوق دفعت
ماما لتعوضه
لم يبقى لها ما تنفقه
قالت هيا نذهب دقدق لكن هذا لم يعجبه دق
دق دق دق يا دقدق دق دق دق دق يا دقدوق
وبكى دقدق اين اللعبه
قالت ماما لن اجلبها
لا نملك ما لم يكفيها بشقاوتك لن تملكها
بشقاوتك لن تملكها
دقدق عاد الى البيت من السوق يشعر بالندم
لافعاله اين السياره والبوق اين السياره
والبوق
[موسيقى]